we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
here is a very fair question
about electric vehicles let's take a
listen
hey david i just have a question about
electric cars i'm all for it the only
thing is that electricity still is
produced with coal and natural gas and
fossil fuels so
how
is it that
it's going to save anything because i
feel like what we're doing is removing
the fuel from the actual car just to a
power plant in someone's neighborhood
hopefully there's a better answer there
is so here's the deal first of all it is
not true
that all electricity comes from fossil
fuels but most electricity still does
come from fossil fuels although it is
diminishing in the united states i've
spoken to energy
activists and technologists about this
exact issue you plug in the electric car
great the car drives around and there's
no emissions
but that electricity
came from fossil fuels first of all
you can power electric vehicles with
renewably sourced electricity
i have solar panels
and then i've got the electric car
so
it's coming from the sun now the solar
panels have
some of a carbon footprint that's true
they were manufactured and they were
shipped but it is lower but you can
power electric vehicles with renewables
you can generate electricity with solar
and wind you've also got non-renewable
but more efficient geothermal
new safe nuclear i'm not a nuclear
nuclear activist but i recognize that if
we built new nuclear now it would not be
like what there was 50 years ago okay
fine we don't even need to get into it
most of the electricity is not coming
from renewables but you can get uh
electricity from renewables so if you're
driving around in a gas-powered car
you're burning fuel
and
as more electricity comes from
renewables you're still driving around
in a gas-powered car there's no way
to make the gas-powered car renewable
if you have the electric car as
electricity transitions away from fossil
fuels
more and more vehicle miles are being
powered by renewable energy okay that's
number one
second
even if electricity is coming from say
uh you know i don't know
some kind of fossil fuel
if the fossil fuel is all being burned
in one place
rather than coming out of a million
vehicle tailpipes
you still have a better chance at
figuring out how to capture the
emissions from those fossil fuels
all at the power plant rather than
having to figure out what to do with a
million different tail pipes that are
driving around so
you're kind of just pushing up the
energy ladder you're obviously
completely right that right now most
electricity still does come from fossil
fuels but it doesn't have to
um and more importantly that's going to
transition over time
that's the answer you know we we've
interviewed energy experts on this and
i've spoken to them personally and and
that's essentially the way it works uh
and uh the transition that we need to
keep pushing is for more and more
electricity
and this is by the way the same reason
that
if you have an electric oven
once the electricity comes from a
renewable
you've closed the loop if you have a gas
oven
no matter what you're burning fossil
fuels and that's a lot of the reason why
one of the big moves right now in
renewable energy is let's start
retrofitting an entire go building by
building you put solar panels on the
roof
you put in an electric heat pump mini
split type system for heating you put in
an electric oven it's now and you put in
a car charger and then you you plug in
your car you've now gone from the roof
to the garage so to speak on electric
and it can come from renewable energy so
that's why there's so much focus on that
right now we have a great bonus show for
you today
new york as the pandemic wayne's
wants to get people riding the subway
again
one of the reasons a lot of people
aren't going back to the new york
subways is because there are lots of
people
living in the subways and there are more
incidents of sucker punches and people
being pushed in front of trains that are
being reported on i don't know if it's
happening more but it's being reported
on it more and new york city wants to
deal with that but how are they going to
deal with that is it going to be
oppressive we're going to talk about
that number two democrats have again
introduced a bill to eliminate these tax
subsidies when sports teams build new
stadiums
maybe will it pass this time we will
discuss and we have a new study that
claims
that when there are stand your ground
laws enacted
homicides go up 11
not
justifiable uses of guns for
self-defense
legal homicides illegal homicides go up
11 percent we're gonna talk about that
on the bonus show
all of those stories and more are at
your fingertips when you sign up at
joinpackman.com you can use the code wow
22 on our website to get a discount we
will speak to you then